[Music]
did millie think nothing could be finer
than a secret call to china
i'm just gonna sit here
yep he was the inept general who gave
beijing a ringy ding ding
i love that
all right according to a new book out
next week by bob woodward and robert
costa
joint chiefs chairman mark milley was so
fearful trump would start a war with
china which is absurd
that he secretly called the top chinese
general twice assuring him trump
wouldn't attack
now it would have been nice if he had
asked to stop releasing deadly airborne
pathogens all over the world
but you know maybe next phone call
even more damning millie uh reportedly
told china quote if we're going to
attack i'm going to call you ahead of
time
well that's courteous
so what did he say when the chinese
called him back hold on i'm kissing the
taliban's ass on line one
the pentagon tells fox news millie's
calls were not secret and happen all the
time between military leaders although
not so much between the good ones i
doubt patton ever messaged rommel on
linkedin i don't think linkedin existed
back then but we get the point
but try telling that to millie's
defenders in the media
i'm sorry this is republicans don't like
this
this is something are you so stupid i
just got to ask are you so stupid are
you so ignorant of how things work that
you don't know that from time to time
generals talk to generals this is going
to play out on twitter this is going to
be completely polarized either there's
going to be you know general milley as a
traitor or general millie is a patriot
that's already started to occur and
let's stick to the facts and the facts
are we had an unbalanced presidency god
bless general milly for straightening
things out i know that the chain of
command is sacrificed i understand that
but this was an emergency
okay i could listen to her for
never ironically one man calling the
general out was trump critic alex
vindeman tweeting if this is true
general milly must resign you can't
simply walk away from that well
walking away seems like something milly
would do think about how he walked away
from afghanistan he's a walking disaster
who seems more concerned about the
feelings of the author of white
fragility than he does the officers he
commands and he sure sucks at booking
flights so maybe he should walk what do
you think terence should he resign at
this point
you know what general silly milly
this man is a traitor in my opinion yes
he is he is that's pretty strong that is
pretty strong but that's what i believe
and that's what it is i believe mm-hmm
you are
that those are no fans of millie and
first of all it makes me sick to my
stomach that all these people stab trump
in the back
you go behind his back call in china you
you you are more worried about china
than you are about our people in
afghanistan
you are not a patriot that's a good
point you are not a true american
this this is absolutely disgusting and
actually he should be arrested i mean he
admitted to calling
china
and this claim he's going to give them a
warning if we are going to attack whose
side are you on okay well this gets this
gets me to a point cheryl that a lot of
this does sound kind of crazy do you
think a lot of this is just
like for example who actually thinks
that we were going to invade china this
sounds like something woodward would
have made up i don't know i mean it's
like two terences if if everything is
true terence is right but what if it's
not true like it's so outrage do you buy
this well before i answer that i'm
really embarrassed because when your
staff said we were talking about millie
i'm thinking millie vanilla oh yes
nether than their emmy's back
but like millie vanilli general milly
may have had some secrets to hide if
true there you go you bring up a good
point about woodward i actually
personally know someone who is directly
quoted in a woodward book
who never spoke to him who tried to get
it corrected because the quote was wrong
and couldn't get that fixed so
um i think it rings a little bit true
but how can i ask you a question why is
i'm the host of the show
please go ahead yes
how does how do people keep having
woodward in the white house i mean trump
even had him in the white house where
does he sit what does he do i was at the
wild house i never saw woodward there
like where is he all the time doing this
stuff do you know i mean what's the deal
don't um didn't he interview
the former c.i.a director on his
deathbed but right nobody saw him come
in or out of the hospital
yeah yeah yeah i don't know i want that
kind of job me too or you don't have to
do anything don't have to be i mean
he's nowhere to be found yes tyrus
thoughts
uh you know
i just feel like this this whole thing
is is well it's a scientific word from
looking for
across the board uh i think
there's no reason there is no reason for
millie to resign because he's right
where he should be in this awoke
administration what we are seeing is
what we are getting him leaving and
going is just going to be more of the
same thing right to succeed in this new
administration you got to bury
everything that was in the last
administration uh that's yep so that's
number one two i never thought that we
were defcom five with china yeah i don't
think that was that issue if there was
the if trump is the bully that you say
he is you don't what if you're six eight
you don't walk up to the other six eight
guy and go what's up bro what you want
to do you go to the five four guy
you know you go to a north korea or
someplace small like that you go hey
i'm saying that seems more like would be
in line with this deranged i mean they
they talk about president trump the same
way a lot of my exes talk about me very
unfavorable
i'm deranged i had delusions of grandeur
i acted buff but i was really chunky
like they would say
just unflattering things right that
could be true could not be true but no
matter what makes me look like a jerk
yeah right and you know even president
trump's rebuttal
was i don't know what you did to him but
it was like well if this truly happened
then i would have fired him and died he
handed it like an adult he's not giving
them what they're used to right so they
have to expound you know i don't think
milly's been on the phone with anyone
more than five minutes other than doing
like a pizza order or something
i just can't see this dude doing that i
mean he's he's a part of the woke
administration why change the story
afghanistan is ugly enough but you know
yeah it could have happened so far like
it like cat maybe he thought he would be
seen as a hero but here's the thing if
we had known about this early on milly
might have been gone and we wouldn't
have had this mess in afghanistan
yeah i just think taking the bigger
picture don't do that
i'm gonna do it no i'm gonna do it i
don't want the big picture well this guy
does
uh millie
like he really
really sucks at his job yes he really
just sucks at his job i mean all those
little stars that he wears
he got for lying about a war just so he
could get those stars at the expense of
american lives
so with this story and this whole news
cycle is all surrounded did this happen
did it not happen should it be fired
should not be fired i'm just sitting
here like can somebody please explain to
me why regardless of this even that this
guy deserves to stay yeah no that's the
whole thing you know people it's like
it's al capone getting busted for his
taxes right this is the story that makes
him go this is great like i got fired
from a ruby tuesday for a lot less and
ruby tuesday is actually not in the
business of sending young people to die
that is true well have you ever had some
of their apps
thank you
i kid i love me at ruby tuesday i'm
actually applauding for that i'm still
eating there after they fired me so yeah
i don't know named is that named after a
rolling stone song or uh i don't know i
don't know i didn't really thought it
was named i didn't read through all the
pamphlets no there's no ruby tuesday are
you sure i you know what i don't know i
don't know lying through my teeth all
right
unsubstantiated
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else